at 53 I'm looking good I can get any man
I want you know why because I'm a body
cam but I'm going to be what all the men
want you know what I mean rubbish
it's rubbish
the more Barrel I'm gonna get exactly
and you can't get blood out of a stone I
don't care how good I look you can't
breathe after a certain amount if you're
gonna say oh yeah the exception can have
a baby at 40. yeah you want to go and be
in the playground
but the women don't want children
it's what the men want women are not
listening to when they're mental but men
somehow have to shut up and listen to
where women are talking about what you
want when a man's telling you what I
want a man saying this is what I want
and the women like nah nah